WHEN THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED
WITHHOLDING FUNDS FROM
SANCTUARY CITIES IN ORDER TO
TRY TO GET THEM TO OBEY, THERE
WAS OUTRAGE IN THE USUAL
COURSES BUT GUESS WHAT NOW YOU
HAVE DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS
PULLING EXACTLY THE SAME TRICK
SAYING THEY’RE GONNA WITHHOLD
FUNDS FROM LOCAL AREAS THAT
DON’T ENFORCE THEIR SHUTDOWN
AND THEIR DOING THIS EVEN AS
WE ARE SEEING THE INCREDIBLE
COST WHICH IS THE CLOSURE OF
SCHOOLS AND CHILDREN’S MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE GOVERNORS ARE
THREATENING TO WITHHOLD FUNDS
AND THERE’S NOT A PEEP FROM
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE
COMPLAINING WHEN DONALD TRUMP
THREATENED THE SAME THING IS.
LISTEN TO THIS LANGUAGE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> THESE FOLKS ARE CHOOSING TO
CAVE INTO THIS CORONAVIRUS AND
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR COWARDLY
ACT.
>> WHAT IT TYRANT HE IS.
I COULDN’T BELIEVE IT WHEN I
HEARD THAT.
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU HAVE THESE GOVERNORS NOW
THAT ARE SO OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THE CITIZENS THEY REPRESENT.
IF THEY DIDN’T HAVE DOUBLE
STANDARDS THEY WOULDN’T HAVE
STANDARDS AT ALL.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
ACTUALLY ENFORCE IMMIGRATION
POLICY THROUGH THE DIRECTION
OF FEDERAL FUNDS AND WHEN THEY
WANT TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE THEIR
OWN OUT OF TOUCH RULING CLASS
PROPOSALS THAT USE THE VERY
SAME TACTICS THAT THEY ACCUSE
THE PRESIDENT OF SO NOW YOU’RE
SEEING THE TALE OF TWO
AMERICAS.
YOU SEE THESE GOVERNORS LIKE
TOM WOLF AND OTHER GOVERNORS
LIKE ANDREW CUOMO AND GAVIN
NEWSOM THAT KEEP DIGGING INTO
THESE FAILED PROPOSALS THAT
THEIR CITIZENS ARE STARTING TO
RESIST AND PART OF IT BEING.
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU AND I HAVE REALLY TRIED TO
ARTICULATE THAT PEOPLE ARE
UPSET.
THEY WANT THEIR LIBERTY BACK
IN THEIR FREEDOM BACK AND IT
IS ESSENTIAL MORE THAN EVER.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> FOR EXAMPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA
THERE SAYING YOU CAN’T EVEN IF
YOUR COUNTY MIGHT BE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT, YOU
CAN’T GO YOUR OWN WAY.
THAT IS JUST THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT OUR CONSTITUTION WAS ALL
ABOUT WHICH IS A
DECENTRALIZATION OF POWER.
>> I’M IN FLORIDA RIGHT NOW.
FLORIDA IS HANDLING THIS VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
THEY’VE LEFT IT UP TO THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES.
SOME COUNTIES SPARSELY
POPULATED HAVE HAD VERY LITTLE
PROBLEM.
THEY’VE HAD VERY FEW CASES IN
DEATH, OTHER PARTS OF FLORIDA
HAS HAD VERY HIGH
CONCENTRATION SO HE’S LEFT IT
UP TO THE COUNTIES, THE
COUNTIES IN MANY CASES HAVE
LEFT IT UP TO THE MAYOR.
WHY, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO THE GROUND TO KNOW
THEIR POPULATION, THEY KNOW
THEIR COMMUNITIES, THEY KNOW
WHICH COMMUNITIES HAVE A
PROBLEM, WHICH COMMUNITIES
DON’T AND AS LONG AS EVERYONE
IS FOLLOWING THE COMMON SENSE
THING LIKE SOCIAL DISTANCING,
WASH YOUR HANDS, ET CETERA,
THEN IT REALLY SHOULD BE LEFT
UP TO THE SMALLEST GROUP OF
SOCIETY TO FIGURE OUT, AND I
WANT TO CONTRAST THIS TO
CHINA.
CHINA IS THE ULTIMATE
EXPRESSION OF AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNMENT.
IT’S A TOTAL SURVEILLANCE
STATE.
THEY REQUIRE, EVEN CHINA
SURVEILLANCE STATE THAT IT IS
IS HAVING SEPARATE REGULATIONS
WHETHER YOU’RE IN WUHAN OR
BEIJING OR SHANGHAI SO EVEN
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE, EVEN
THE MOST AUTHORITARIAN NATION
IN THE WORLD ISN’T QUITE AS
AUTHORITARIAN AS SOME OF THE
OPENERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT THE LANGUAGE
THERE FROM TOM WOLF.
IT’S JUST STAGGERING TO INSULT
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND EARN A
LIVING.
I COULDN’T BELIEVE THAT
LANGUAGE.
>> AND I THINK THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE TO IS A LOT OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AREN’T
MAKING ANY SENSE AND QUITE
HONESTLY WERE BEING GOVERNED
BY MORONS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CITY, IT’S TRUE, THE MAYOR
DELAYED REOPENING BECAUSE OF A
SEROLOGICAL STUDY THAT SHOWS
90% OF THE CITIZEN HAS NOT
CONTRACTED CORONAVIRUS, THEY
THINK ONLY 10% HAD SO HE’S NOT
GOING TO REOPEN BUT THE REASON
THEY HAVEN’T IS BECAUSE THE
CITY’S BEEN CLOSE SO HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO GET TO HIGHER
LEVELS WITH THE CITY SHUT
DOWN.
IT JUSTIFIES LOGIC, IT MAKES
NO SENSE AND THEN YOU HAVE
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYING NO ONE
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED FOR
NURSING HOME DEATHS WELL OF
COURSE HE HOLDS THAT THEORY,
IT WAS HIS MANDATE AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION’S MANDATE THAT
SENT COVERT PATIENTS INTO THE
NURSING HOME AND INFECTED
OTHER PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE DIED BECAUSE
OF THAT FAILED POLICY, AND
LASTLY WE’VE HAD SO MANY
OFFICIALS TELL US THAT TESTING
IS THE KEY TO REOPENING, WELL
CUOMO WAS COMPLAINING THE
OTHER DAY THAT ONE THIRD OF
THE TESTING CAPABILITIES ARE
NOT BEING UTILIZED BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP
SO THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE HERE
IS THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
MAKE NO SENSE, THEY’RE NOT
DOING IT ACCORDING TO THE DATA
AND I THINK THAT’S WHY SOME OF
THE PEOPLE ARE REALLY
DISTRUSTING THEIR LEADERS
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU JUST REMINDED ME OF
SOMETHING I’VE BEEN WANTING TO
DO ON THE SHOW FOR LONG TIME.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY BRILLIANT.
IT’S A TEASE FOR HIS UPCOMING
SHOW.
QUICK LAST WORD ON THE POINT I
MADE AT THE BEGINNING OF THAT,
CHARLIE, WHY AREN’T SCHOOLS
BEING REOPENED.
YOU CAN’T GET THE ECONOMY
REOPEN IF PARENTS CAN’T GO TO
WORK.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE REPRESENT HIGH SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SHOWN THROUGH
DATA TO NOT BE AS AT RISK AS
OTHER PARTS OF THE POPULATION
YET THERE ARE SCHOOLS THAT
WILL NEVER REOPEN.
THE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS IN NEW
JERSEY, THE ARCHDIOCESE SAID